los logros están diseñados para hacer
esos pequeños trofeos digitales de los
cuales alardear y mostrar orgullosamente
en tu perfil puedes obtener logros por
darle una patadita a un soldado por
dispararle a alguien en la cara o
incluso por tirarle vómito a otro
jugador la verdad es que ahora puedes
conseguir logros por casi cualquier cosa
literalmente cualquier cosa no puede ser
tan
fácil
ah Ay qué fácil el punto es que estos
logros están diseñados para recompensar
tu esfuerzo y hacerte sentir bien Oh eso
pensábamos porque con el tiempo los
desarrolladores se cansaron de ser
amables y comenzaron a agregar logros
con el único objetivo de avergonzarte o
simplemente
ofenderte sé que a todos nos gusta la
sensación de conseguir un buen logro
Pero créeme no quieres tener los
siguientes en tu perfil estos son los
logros más vergonzosos y ofensivos que
no quieres
desbloquear la conspiración born es un
juego inspirado en estas películas si
las has visto sabrás que tratan de un
agente mamadísimo que muy rara vez falla
un tiro por lo que en el juego si
deshonras el nombre del poderoso born y
fallas el 9% de tus disparos en una
misión el juego te dará un sutil mensaje
explorando los niveles del bizarro juego
de Padre de Familia en una habitación
podrás encontrar a qum amarrado a una
cama y vestido de bebé si no sé qué
decirte estoy tan confundido como
tú si en vez de ignorar esto como una
persona normal decides por alguna razón
cósmica que quieres quedarte ahí
mirándolo por un buen rato Qué raro eres
estás
enfermo los juegos de Príncipe de Persia
Siempre fueron bastante difíciles
después de todo incluyeron la mecánica
de devolver el tiempo porque sabían que
la ibas a [__] más de lo usual en las
Arenas olvidadas Si ves que te están
pateando el trasero más de lo normal y
decides bajar la dificultad en el menú
de pausa desbloqueará un logro que dice
no le diremos a
nadie Girls of War 4 está lleno de armas
enormes y poderosas Así que es normal
que mientras te acostumbras al juego
mueras accidentalmente
Pero qué imbécil pero si te las arreglas
para matarte Tú solito cuatro veces en
el multijugador el juego te recompensará
con el logro más agallas que
habilidad los juegos de pelea son
difíciles y cuando perdemos no queremos
que nadie se entere de lo malos que
somos pero A deedra Life 4 eso le
importa un [__] Pues si pierdes 20
peleas seguidas en el online te darán un
trofeo para marcar tu vergüenza por el
resto de tu vida este logro ni siquiera
lo oculta bajo un hombre discreto o algo
solo te restriegan la cara lo malo que
eres me ofendiste Shrek me ofendiste
regacho
la premisa entera de postal 2 se trata
de ser el mayor que orón que pueda ser
tanto así que hasta incluye una mecánica
de orinar para que molestes a todo
humano que se acerque a ti guacatelas
qué asco una prueba del humor tan oscuro
del juego está en el logro llamado es
estéril y me gusta el sabor qué
conseguirás si orinas directamente hacia
arriba en los juegos de disparos solo
existen dos tipos de jugadores los que
se avientan a toda madre a disparar y
matar a sus enemigos como todos unos
espartanos y los que les gusta sentarse
en una esquina como
ratas Halo 4 sabe esto muy bien así que
diseñaron una sutil estrategia para
castigarte Pues si te quedas quieto en
un solo lugar por más de 5 minutos el
mismo sistema te dirá que te levantes y
juegues el maldito
juego en la serie yakuza tienes un
montón de actividades en las que gastar
tu tiempo puedes partirte la madre
bailar o cantarte unos temazos si aún
teniendo todo esto decides ir a un cine
erótico podrás elegir el video más
sabrosón de mujeres reales en 4k con lo
que tu personaje se estrangular la
nutria ganándose este trofeo cochino
degenerado para conseguir el logro
aplastado en el juego de Los Simpson lo
único que tienes que hacer es morir
muchas veces más que el logro en sí Lo
gracioso es su
[Risas]
descripción si has jugado Lollipop
chains deberías avergonzarte pero si
tienes este logro deberías avergonzarte
aún más pues si tratas de mirar por
debajo de la falda de la protagonista el
juego te otorga un logro para ti
puerco
cochino lo gracioso es que nier autómata
hicieron algo muy similar aquí hay que
aclarar algo yo sé que 2b es uno de los
personajes más suculentamente suculentos
de los videojuegos eso no se discute
pero Contrólate con un [__] si
manipulas la cámara y tratas de ver por
debajo de la falda de 2b más de 10 veces
el juego razonablemente no dudará En
regañarte qué
[Música]
rico snake es uno de los personajes más
profesionales de los videojuegos pero
también tiene su lado oscuro y es que en
la versión HD de metal Gear solid 2
podrás meterte a un casillero que tiene
un póster de una modelo Y si te quedas
ahí por mucho tiempo snake comenzará a
ahorcar el gansu sin misericordia alguna
y ocelot te llamará para regañarte Por
hacerlo en tus horas
[Música]
laborales
el juego super hot para realidad virtual
toma alrededor de unas tres a 5 horas
para completar no es un juego
particularmente largo pero tener unas
gafotas pegadas a tu cara durante tantas
horas no es que sea lo más recomendable
En todo caso si completas el juego de
golpe y sin descansar serás recompensado
de una manera bastante
única
God of War no es un juego muy difícil
que
digamos pero si mueres demasiadas veces
el juego insultar tu habilidad
ofreciéndote bajar la dificultad y para
agregar sala a la herida
independientemente de lo que elijas el
juego te termina de humillar con un
logro llamado me están pateando el
trasero es la forma que el juego tiene
para decirte que eres un
asco
Lara croft y el templo de Osiris es un
juego de acción bien rarito en donde
puedes jugar con tres de tus amigos los
mapas están plagados con trampas
mortales y bichos asesinos Así que morir
no es
difícil pero si al final de la partida
eres el jugador que más veces murió el
juego tratará de consolarte diciendo Hey
al menos Eres el mejor en algo nadie se
ha preocupado tanto por
mí si South Park nos enseñó algo es que
nunca jamás bajo ninguna circunstancia
le debes disparar a alguien en las
bolas Eso no se hace
[__] no puedes dispararle a los penes
Está bien lo siento y the other World
está perfectamente consciente de esto
este juego tiene una mecánica en donde
puedes ralentizar el tiempo para atacar
a tus enemigos pero si eres un psicópata
y usas esta habilidad para dispararle a
30 30 enemigos en la entrepierna Ah
miula te saltará un logro para marcar tu
deshonra alcanzar el prestigio en Call
of Duty World at War no era una tarea
fácil tenías que alcanzar el nivel
máximo en el juego y luego reiniciar tu
puntaje para volverlo a hacer Esto es
algo que solo los jugadores más
dedicados llegaron a hacer
lastimosamente cuando el juego ve que
has alcanzado el nivel máximo de
prestigio en lugar de felicitarte O al
menos darte una palmadita en la espalda
te dirá que ya es hora de parar y de
tomar un poco de
Sol no pueden hacerme esto a mí no saben
cuánto he
[Música]
sacrificado el mayor reconocimiento que
puedes conseguir en un juego es el
platino un trofeo que se te da cuando
consigues todos los demás logros Así que
si le metiste tanto empeño y dedicación
pues [__] por lo menos un poco de
respeto no bueno undertale piensa un
poco diferente ya que si juegas a la
versión de PlayStation y consigues los
29 logros del juego desbloqueará el
grandioso platino que te dirá en la cara
no tienes nada mejor que
hacer y ahí lo tienen 18 logros de los
que no estábamos tan orgullosos Ahora
quiero que me seas honesto y me digas en
los comentarios Cuál de estos logros
tienes desbloqueado en tu perfil e no te
voy a juzgar si coleccionas logros de
poca madre solo pregunto si llegaste
hasta aquí te agradezco por ver el video
por ahí te dejo mis redes y un par de
videos geniales Espero que estén bien
Cuídense mucho y nos vemos luego hasta
la
próxima
[Música]
se